From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Like good afternoon, this is David Cline for the Civil Rights History Project.
I work in the History Department at Virginia Tech and have the honor of working with the Civil Rights History Project of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is June 28, 2016, and I'm in San Diego, California.
This project is also co-sponsored by the Southern Oral History Program at UNC Chapel Hill and, as I said, by the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian.
Today we have with us Guha Shankar is in the room, behind the camera is John Bishop of Media Generation.
We have the distinct honor to be visiting with Harold Brown here in San Diego.
And this is the one time that I will coach you at all is just if you could start with a complete sentence, then we'll just go into conversation.
But my name is, or I am, and your name and the year of your birth and where you're born.
My name is Harold K. Brown known, better known as Hal Brown.
I was born in York, Pennsylvania, and migrated to San Diego through San Diego State University in 1953.
And you were born when?
I was born in 1934, and I am the son of Mrs. Emma Brown, and I am one of seven siblings.
And could we start with your childhood? You said you were born in Pennsylvania, but if you could tell us a little bit about what you're up bringing with like and who your people were.
I like to start by saying that, you know, I'm trying to answer the question is what breeds a civil rights activist or a civil rights militant as we were called in the 60s.
So I grew up in a community, mostly farm community of approximately 1% or less black citizens.
And your Pennsylvania was typical of the United States of America at that time.
There was segregated housing.
So I grew up in a segregated, what was called in those days a colored community.
And we were all rather poor, not poor to the extent that we didn't have food and we didn't have clothing.
But we were all in pretty much the same boat. It was a group of people who had very few opportunities, if any.
We lived there, we went to segregated schools up until the seventh grade is when we integrated.
And so jobs were scarce for our families and so income was very, very low.
So that's the environment I grew up in.
And there are parts of Pennsylvania, I feel like a lot of people don't know this, that we're really, really rough.
Absolutely. Absolutely. People don't think of the north. People from the south don't think of the north as being a tough place to live for black people descending some slave.
But it was. And when people moved from when blacks moved from the south to the north, they found that there was a lot of hardship there in terms of segregated housing and discriminated employment.
And so that's what I grew up in and faced a lot of insults. One of the stories I tell is that I caught my introduction really to racism in America.
And that was when I was in elementary school, we had to go to a black and quotes elementary school.
And when we would walk all somewhere around maybe five miles to the school, pass white schools to get there.
And there was a chain works factory on en route to our school.
And the men used to hang out the windows on the upper floors and just hurl all kinds of racial insults, calling us names all the whole time.
And it just happened every day. And so that was my introduction at age six.
And your children and those are adults. Yes, just children.
So hindsight helps us in these things. Looking back, can you start to see where a race consciousness of some kind started to form for you?
Absolutely. I joke about it when I tell people that when I was born and came out of the womb, I saw the doctor and some nurses and they were all white.
And so I didn't know I was black until my mother took me home to this colored community.
And then I began to look around and I saw, you know, these people were different colors than once I saw when I came into this world.
But that was sort of the introduction that I like to talk about because it illustrates that there was a difference right from the beginning.
And I attribute the psychological and mental exposure to this which had its impact right from the beginning.
And the names and the insults and the observation of no blacks being in positions of importance in the city, all of them were whites and mostly white males.
And so this I attribute to the learning in America of a young black kid growing up.
And so there was just a building on that, you know, from going from a segregated elementary school to an integrated junior high school and the impact that that had the difference.
And I suspect it must have had an impact on the white students as well. But that being the only black in a classroom and experiencing the officers of the school, the teachers of the school, the administrators of the school, you know, there's all, you're in a white world.
And here you are being the victim of insults that come and everything that you see just about substantiates the fact that you are less than the rest of them.
And that builds into the mind of a child. And I guess leads to the point where the psychological tests where black kids say select a white kid is being the good kid and the smart kid as opposed to selecting a black kid.
Now, were there any forces that you can remember whether at home or in the school or elsewhere that were pushing against that for you that were giving you a different message, a message about black pride?
Well, the one that I cite the most is that the contradiction takes place when I entered junior high school.
My home-room teacher, Cassandra Shea, just sort of adopted me and she was a white math teacher and my home-room teacher. But she introduced me the concept of college, which I didn't know anything about, never heard of.
She introduced me to that and explained that out of the blue that you want to think about going to college, Harold, and she explained how she had, she went to college and her family wasn't, didn't have the financial ability to put her to college.
She got a job and she worked through college like cleaning people's home houses and so forth. And so, you know, there here was a, where's a, made an impression on me. And then when my football coach there in junior high school says to me, how, you know, you ought to be a dentist.
And I go, you know, dentists. I mean, that was farthest from me. I never knew a dentist, never saw anybody, you know, a black professional just was not heard. We had a few black teachers who taught in black schools.
But to have a black person in the community as a dentist or a doctor and so forth, we had one black doctor and no black dentist. But that coach of mine introduced me to some things that I had not even thought about.
So, you know, there's this, this, this, now this contradiction begins to build in is that, you know, here, here is all this white world and that's bad. But then here's some people who are the same color, but who have shown a great amount of love and acceptance and encouragement and so forth.
And, you know, I just think a young people growing up, that's a lot to deal with. The mind is young and being developed and when you have these kinds of things which are really unnecessary.
So, I credit our, the forefathers of this country for not looking into the future for enough to prevent all this stuff.
During your schooling then, and into high school, was there any black history at all that was taught or no?
In fact, I can remember and as I used to go back to Pennsylvania on vacation and talk with my friends who I grew up with, went to school.
And our black friends used to laugh about this because the only thing that we saw interracially was slaves pictured and when that would happen, when they would show those pictures and everything that these blacks in the cotton fields picking cotton and everything.
And then, we as blacks would scringe down in our seats and try to, try to disappear from, and then of course we found the humor in it as we became adults and we would laugh about it.
And then there was another example of, of non history, non black history teaching, there was our music teacher there during your high school would always, somehow find the song Old Black Joe".
And she would play that, it seems like every class that we had every day.
She would play this thing and she would sit at the piano and we would all have to sing.
Now remember, you're the only black or maybe a couple in the class of all whites.
And when you did that, you know, black students, like guests, which is grabbed their chairs
tightly and kind of get down and hope that they could just disappear and get through this.
And again, as adults, we laugh about it.
So no, I didn't learn anything about black history until I graduated from college.
And that's when I began on my own to read and learn about the history of black folks in
America.
So can you tell me a little bit about your journey toward college?
You were an athlete in high school and that was part of what brought you to San Diego.
Yes.
Can you tell us a little bit about that?
That was really what brought me to San Diego.
And I started out as a basketball and baseball player since elementary school.
And I was in high school.
I became quite popular as a sort of an accomplished athlete.
I was selected as the all-state basketball player in my senior year and followed in my brother's
foot steps because he had also achieved that as the first basketball player in the history
of our school to achieve that status of all-state status.
And I was a second.
So I was very popular as athletes are in junior high school and in high school.
And I was a baseball player, as I mentioned, in addition to basketball.
I wasn't tall enough to receive any real attention to be recruited to these colleges and so
forth.
But two people who had attended San Diego State, older fellows who were in the Navy and
they had been to San Diego and actually ended up playing basketball for San Diego State.
And as I came along in my senior year, when they came home to York, they approached me and
encouraged me to go there.
Well, my counselors had already sort of programmed me to go to Penn State, which I did.
And I attended Penn State on a scholarship, on a basketball scholarship, which paid for
my tuition, but that was about it.
And there was no money for rent or food or anything like that.
So I eventually left there and went to accept a trial with the St. Louis Browns in Thomasville,
Georgia.
And I did that.
And after a couple of injuries, I went back home to York and wrote the coach at San Diego
State and said that I was ready to come out there.
And so I did that and I came to San Diego and was because I was a transfer, I was in
Eligible to play.
I had to wait out a year.
So the coach at San Diego State told me, he said, how would you do that?
I have you go to the junior college first and just, you won't miss your education, but
you won't be able to play at San Diego State, but you can play there and it won't be counted
against your eligibility.
I saw, that sounds like a good plan.
Well, it was not correct because when I went there and signed up for the classes and
so forth, and then to junior college, it would have counted.
So I didn't play until I got to San Diego State and I was in between junior college and
San Diego State.
I was drafted into the Army.
And so I spent two years in the Army and then I went to San Diego State.
So did you end up playing for the St. Louis Browns?
No.
I did not.
One of the things that I talk about and I try to help with younger people is making sure
that they have someone in their lives who can provide some guidance and advice.
I grew up with a mother and some older siblings, but there wasn't any person in my life other
than in school.
It wasn't any person who really provides this advice and guidance and so on and introduced
me to things that I should be introduced to.
So when I went to an example of this is when I went to the minor league training for the
St. Louis Browns, I went there not knowing that you are expected when you arrive to be
in shape and ready to play ball.
Well my experience was that in York, Pennsylvania, it was cold in the winter and you might get
your glove and ball and start throwing a little bit in the gym, come April and do some running
a little bit.
So when I got there, I was shocked.
I mean, we were going full steam, running wind, windspinths and throwing hard and feeling
and all this stuff and my arm couldn't take it, my legs couldn't take it and so I was playing.
I was a shortstop and I was trying to throw from short to first and needles and things
just felt like all through my arms.
So that was a bad try.
I had to go home and then I just waited my time to throw the next step which was my next
step was okay.
I went back in the college because I wanted to play ball in college and that's what happened.
Ended up at San Diego State.
Let me ask you, I want to ask about your military service but just a question about racial dynamics
on teams and in the locker room.
Was that a different situation or more of the same?
Can you tell us a little bit about what your experiences were there?
I think sports is such a great opportunity to address the racial issue.
Some of the friends that I really got to have growing up through sports and maybe there
were a couple or so other white students who I got to be friends with.
But the ones I really got to know and have some association with beyond the school boundaries
was with those teammates and all through junior high school that was true.
And of course you have the blacks who made the team.
Of course we all lived in the same neighborhoods or close by and we knew each other.
We saw each other after school and we had a separate facility, a separate recreational
facility called Crispus Attucks Center, community center that we blacks went to and so we
were together but getting relationships with your white classmates and so forth is really
hard.
If it were not for the sports program, it probably just would hardly happen at all.
And that and all went through junior high school.
In high school it was even more difficult to have relationships with the white students
even the schoolmates, even your teammates because they came from different parts of the
county and you saw them and you played and that was it.
Wasn't like you were going over to each other's houses?
No, nothing I could.
You didn't get to really know them and they didn't get to know you.
In college, playing ball in college it was the same thing.
I mean, you have very few blacks on the team and the white players you saw at practice and
maybe in the cafeteria once in a while and that was it.
The black players, we were together after the practice during the evenings on weekends
sometimes.
While sports offered a great opportunity, they still left a lot to be desired and I regret
that more was not done during that period when I was an athlete.
As you were saying before, did you go out to San Diego and then went for the year of junior
college and then the military came calling?
Can you tell us about that?
When I left San Diego, when I left school after junior college for the summer, I went
back to Pennsylvania and what year was that?
That was 1953.
When I went back to New York, I inquired about because I didn't want to make a trip back
to California and then get drafted and then I have to return back to Pennsylvania and be
inducted from Pennsylvania.
So I inquired when I was in New York about my status, my draft status and the person told
me, oh, you're right close to being drafted.
Whether that was true or not, I'm not so sure.
But I said, well, I might as well get it going now and get my two years over.
So that's what I did.
That's right at the end of the Korean War was one heading down.
Right at the end of the Korean War and I did my training in Georgia.
I was going to say Thomas, we're going to get mixed up with my baseball.
It was with the Camp Gordon.
What was the situation like there at that time?
As long as you stayed on the base, things were okay mostly.
It wasn't like there was any, you could mix with males but there wasn't any mixing with
females as a black person.
Now the movies, the mess hall and so forth where you ate and all that was fine.
There was no parks.
As long as you stayed on the post, when you went off post in the town, that's when you ran
in the trouble.
That's where I saw signs as we would be walking down the street.
You'd see signs saying no, no, no, no, Jews or niggers allowed, no dogs, Jews or niggers
allowed.
You'd see that kind of stuff.
We limited our contact, we just didn't go into town very much.
That was my basic training.
Then I was then sent to New Jersey at Fort Momoth where that was my permanent station there.
How are things in New Jersey?
New Jersey was fine.
We could go to, after hours, we would go out in the town a little bit and go out to the
school bar and guys would have some drinks and so forth.
We never experienced any problems there except for one.
I received an assignment to go to Louisiana on an operation called Operation Sagebrush.
I was assigned to that and we were going to.
What I knew at this point in my life about racism in America, I was not going there.
So in my naivete decided I was going to the post commander and tell him I'm not going
down there.
Here I am just an enlisted man.
I'm not an officer.
I'm an enlisted man.
Even an officer wouldn't do that.
I requested, well I went over and just asked to see and talk with him.
He invited me in and I told him.
I said, as an e-girl, he just does make any sense for me to go to a place where I'm not
wanted and to have to go to the south and be exposed to those conditions.
I'm sure I didn't say it in these words.
I was a young shy kid who was just upset and because I'm afraid I guess.
He looked at me and he listened and he said something.
He returned to your barracks.
I returned to my barracks and we received orders to ship out and I was among those who
shipped out along with all the others and we were shipped down to Louisiana and lived in
the outskirts of the town.
We just stayed out there and going in town.
I think only went in town one time to Shreveport, Louisiana and didn't experience anything but I certainly
didn't notice any integration or anything like that.
We did our time down there and shipped back to Fort Mammoth, New Jersey.
So you did your two years and then back to San Diego?
Yes.
San Diego State was a good experience but at the same time it's just been one incident
after another that spoke to you as a descendant of slaves as a black person, as a negro,
as a colored person.
It just kept coming incident after incident in a reminder form that you are not a first-class
citizen in this country.
My experience at San Diego State, one thing that stands out is that while I was an athlete
I was also interested in student government and so forth.
So I was encouraged to run for an office in student government.
I did.
I won and set on the council, student council.
On that council I was asked to chair a certain committee.
It was called the Constitution's Committee.
That committee was responsible for reviewing the constitutions and charters of all the on-campus
organizations, all the sororities, all the fraternities and so on.
So when I started reviewing these I saw in the charters of the fraternities, of white
fraternities and sororities that it was for white male or white female and in good conscience
I couldn't approve that.
And so I didn't approve them.
And of course my recommendation was to be made to the council and then the council would
bow down.
Well, of course when I didn't approve them that meant they would not receive on-campus
status and all the privileges thereof.
And so of course I was called in by the dean of students and we had a chat about it and
so forth.
And I never found out what actually happened whether or not these people, these organizations
really received on-campus status or probationary status for some reason.
And I didn't push it beyond that.
And that was my experience that really stood out at San Diego State along with the friendship
and the real guidance and love that I received from some of the faculty members at that time.
So again there was sort of a balancing of that.
I think there were about 25 black students in the whole university at that time and out
of an enrollment I think it must have been around the year 7000 something like that.
And here again you sit in the classroom, you're the only black student.
And it's the same thing over again.
You know, I mean you didn't run into any, it wasn't that you've had some great incidents.
But still I mean that's, you know, the black status program was created in this country.
In part to provide some companionship for those of that ethnicity.
And although there was a lot of pushback on that.
But you know, it's your young, you want companionship and friendship and you need that to grow
and so on.
And all students need that.
But when you sit there in a land of what you know to be racist towards you and when you
walk down a street and you're called nigger, you're right there in San Diego.
I mean, you know, I mean that's your life.
And you end up, you know, I guess with some some some feelings, what those feelings happen
to be depends on the individual.
For me it was anger.
I was angry and I knew that I had to do something about it.
I was, but sure, I wasn't in junior high school and I wasn't in high school age.
I had been around a little bit and I mature and the further I went, the more angry I got.
And so that's how I decided when I graduated from San Diego State to join the civil rights
movement.
You got a very small African American community obviously at the school.
What about within the city of San Diego?
Yeah, it was always around 6%.
And as I recall when we were, when we had formed the Congress of Racial Equality here in
San Diego, I recall that the number of blacks in San Diego was at some of the things somewhere
around 60,000.
And I don't know what the San Diego population was, but that number of 60,000 seemed.
It was, well, it was around 6% as I recall.
And so you graduated and but stayed in the city.
What else did you do?
And you said, I want to hear the story of you turning to the civil rights movement, but
what did you do post graduation?
Well, I did post graduate work here at San Diego State in speech pathology.
And I was waiting to see if I could get a job teaching school.
Now here's another thing about where this guidance and counseling for young people is so necessary.
When I was in junior high school and especially in high school, I wanted to be a physical education
teacher and a coach.
That's what I knew and that's where I felt comfortable and that's what I did best.
I liked school and I was good in school, but I excelled in that area.
So and I went to San Diego State, I accomplished that.
My major was in physical education and my minor was in speech correction or the speech pathology
area.
But I wanted to be a coach.
Now, after I graduated, I'm waiting around for a job and it occurs to me.
Wait a minute, they don't hire blacks to coach in high schools.
Now here I am, you know, me all these years, I mean, it looks like I would have put two
and two together through those years.
But for some reason, when I came to San Diego, I graduated from San Diego State, I thought,
okay, I'm going toward my goal, I'll be a coach.
But then, bang, they don't hire you.
And so I tried to get a job just teaching at physical education on the junior high level
or even on the high school level.
So when I applied for a position, not in the city of San Diego, but this was in the city
of La Mesa, California.
And I applied.
And they said the only way they could hire me.
And I think this guy was the superintendent.
Said the only way I could hire me is if they pulled all the teachers in the district
to see if it would be okay to hire a Negro.
So I said, well, forget that.
And I just decided that I was approached by an organization that was starting called
the El Cajon Valley Open Housing Committee.
And they formed to, for the purpose of integrating the neighborhoods in La Mesa, California and El Cajon Valley,
just east of San Diego State.
And so I joined with them.
This was an all white group.
I joined with them.
And then about a year into that.
So I was approached by a black fellow who happened to be one of those meetings that we held.
And he said that they were forming a chapter of core in San Diego.
And would I join with them?
And then I did.
And I think that was 1960.
And so that started my career in core in that year.
But I did get a job teaching school.
I received this position as a result of one of my schoolmates at San Diego State who
knew me.
And I think we were maybe in a class together.
And so he knew me.
And they were looking for a teacher there where he was teaching.
And he recommended to the principal recommended me.
And so they got in touch with me and brought me out for an interview.
And in the meantime, I had no idea that I was going to get a job.
I mean, I was kind of sweating it out.
We were getting close to September.
And I didn't have a job.
So I talked with the principal and everything.
And they hired me.
And I had a great time teaching there for five years.
And before I went into the Peace Corps, I was invited into the Peace Corps to apply for
a position as deputy director, which I did.
And then was assigned to the South Africa, Southern Africa.
So with the Congress of Racial Quality, did you know much about them already before you
heard about this in Diego chapter?
No.
I knew nothing about core.
So there was a meeting to organize it.
And I decided because this was my first year of teaching that I better cool it.
And something told me, look, don't do that your first year.
Let them see what you can do as a teacher.
Once you get a year under your belt, then you can pursue your activities in the civil
rights movement.
So that's what I did.
And fortunately, I was selected as one of the five outstanding new teachers in San Diego.
So I had that under my belt.
And then I decided, OK, I'll go and then I became the chairman of the San Diego Corps.
And we went straight to chairman.
Well, yes.
You didn't mess around.
No.
So this is around 1960.
Correct.
That was about 61.
61.
So where were you in say 1955 when the Montgomery bus boycott was going on?
I had just separated.
No, I was in the, I was still in the army.
I went in in 54 and I was separated from the army in 56.
So I was at Fort Monmouth, NJ then.
And what do you watch in television?
OK, yeah, I was going to say, would you have gotten newspapers or even black newspapers
where they allowed on base?
I know sometimes they weren't.
That were you following the news?
I was following the news through television, but never saw a newspaper.
While I was at Fort Monmouth, NJ, then I would get weekend passes once in a while.
And so I'd go to York and visit my family and of course the papers and the news there.
But I watched on TV, you know, all the civil rights activities that were going on and
some basketball.
OK, so I just wanted to ask that question.
So back to Corr, then, can you tell me about what that was like, organizing the chapter
and what you all recognized as the major challenges in the city and what you wanted to focus?
Yes.
We had a person who I think he was affiliated with National Corr in some way.
And he helped us form the San Diego chapter.
And I remember we met and you know, we wrote up the bylaws, et cetera, et cetera, formed
a 501(c) organization.
Then as we met and I think we were meeting pretty regularly then, we had elections and so
forth.
And they had asked me if I would run for the position of chairman, which I did.
And there was some problems there because prior to that, I had also become a member of
an organization which was known as the Black National Disorganization.
It was the Afro-American Association.
Now, it was labeled, I think, a Black nationalist organization.
That's what the media and this particular thing called this Black Nationalist.
I didn't know what that was at first.
So the purpose of that organization was still there's a need today.
We formed it to educate Black people about the plight of Black people in America, teaching
Black history and having discussions and so forth about the conditions of Black folk in
America.
And so that was a nice experience, a very good experience.
So this connects back to what I asked you earlier if you had had Black history in school.
And this is a program of self-education.
Yes, absolutely.
And my first introduction to many of the books that I have in my library now and discussions
and so forth and I reached a point where I remember, I think the first one I read was
Lerone Bennett Jr Jr by Lerone Bennett Jr and I had discussions with young people about
our history.
And so then when I ran for the position of chairman and became the chairman and the conditions
were deplorable as we found them here in San Diego.
Not only were there segregated schools, but there's I recall there were 19 schools in San
Diego that were segregated.
And we found that to be serious, but we found employment discrimination to be really our
top priority.
And so we worked on the businesses, the companies around San Diego to try to open up these companies
to higher blacks.
Now blacks could not be hired in the grocery stores.
These chain stores and everything.
They didn't hire blacks even as, with because of those, those, those, baggers.
Yes, much less than other positions of cashier and imaginary.
You couldn't even be hired as a bagger.
And there were no freeways back then.
So the downtown, there were no blacks who worked in the downtown.
Just prior to some years before I started in core, they had had some demonstrations against
I think it was Woolworths and because he couldn't sit, he couldn't eat in Woolworths and
it was led by a black dentist, Dr. Kimbrough, who, who, John to Dr. Jack Kimbrough.
And so, you know, the conditions were, I mean, you couldn't rent, you couldn't, you couldn't
live.
You couldn't rent or buy a house or apartment outside of what was called Logan Heights.
Where blacks were forced to live, Logan Heights and now it's known as Southeast and
Logan Heights.
So you had to live in that area.
And then I talk about an example of that is when the young lady that I married in 1967,
she came to San Diego.
She was recruited to San Diego.
You were just starting to talk about the woman that who you were.
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, in 1967.
She was recruited to come to San Diego with general dynamics.
She was as a math major who graduated from Alabama State University.
She came, she was living in Ohio, Columbus, Ohio at the time.
She was recruited to come to San Diego to work for general dynamics as a systems programmer,
computer programmer.
And so, she accepted and she came here and couldn't find a place to live.
She was given a list by general dynamics of places to apartments and houses and so forth
that she could go and well, she would call those places.
And when she would get there, they would say they have a vacancy, of course.
And then when you got there and they saw who she was, we don't rent the Negroes.
So that was it.
She had to go on to the next place.
And so she went there.
She couldn't find a place to live.
And even though she would call and say they had a place, but when she got there, they didn't
have one.
They had just rented it or something.
So she had to stay in the Y until she could find a place to live.
I met her because I was planning to go into business and I was going to leave teaching
and I went to sell new automobiles to kind of get into the field and business.
And when I went in there, she was buying a car so she could get back and forth.
The sales guy introduced us and asked if I would show her where general dynamics was.
And she had only been in San Diego over a day or two.
And so I said, yes.
She complained when she went back.
She complained to the cleaning lady who was black at the Y.
And she said, well, she can't find a place to live.
And so the sales lady said, honey, what you should do.
As a man in town, you should call.
You call how brown.
And so she said, that sounded familiar.
So anyhow, that's how I met her and I started showing her around to find a place to live.
Finally, I was acquainted with an apartment where one of my fellow teachers, I was
a little bit of a living place.
We had had a little party or something over to her house and I remembered that and I thought
that was a nice apartment.
So I said, this would be a nice place for you to live.
Showed her that and she said, oh, yeah, it's nice.
It had a pool there.
So she went in and talked to the manager and the manager said, well, she called first and
he said he had an opening.
And when she went by there and he said, no, he said, well, we just can't rent to knee
girls.
And so she said, well, why don't you say, well, the owner who lives in Canada, I think
he said, doesn't want us to rent to knee girls.
So I was with her and I was sitting over there while she was talking with him and then I got
up and I said, I don't believe that.
And he said, well, that's what he said, no, I don't believe that.
I said, here's what I'll do.
I'll go around, you and I will go around to each apartment and we'll knock on the door
and we'll ask that tenant whether or not they would mind or object to living next to a
person who was a Negro.
I had a little thing on my sleeve.
I was going to go to my friends place first in her apartment.
But he wouldn't do that.
He said, oh, no, no, no, no.
So he said, I'll see what we can do.
We left.
She called back, I guess, the neighbor's next day or so and he said, no, he said the owner
and Canada just didn't want to rent to a Negro.
And so I said, well, you know, I'll tell you what I'm going to do.
I'm going to round up a hundred of my black friends and we're coming over to your apartment
building and we're going to take off our clothes.
We'll have our bathing suit songs and we're all going to get in that pool.
He said, no, no, I'll tell you what.
I think we can.
I think we can rent that rent rent to your apartment.
And that's how she got the apartment.
I had to threaten them with that.
And I guess that imagery was just too much to see all these black folks.
And then all his, those people that he was referring to about moving out, I guess he
visualized everything, all be going if we did that.
So anyhow, that's how she finally got to move in.
So discrimination in housing was terrible.
There were covenants, of course, in places in all the places in the homes and things where
the people couldn't sell their home to a black person.
And so we had a lot of demonstrations against the California Real Estate Association.
And of course we picketed and had sit-ins at various places trying to get jobs for blacks
back in those years.
And our biggest project was against the Bank of America, which that's where I received
my jail sentences from the Bank of America demonstrations and also from the San Diego
Gas and Electric demonstrations.
And what were the goals there, especially with Bank of America?
We wanted them to open their employment to knee-grows back in those years and be the same
thing for the San Diego Gas & Electric.
So at that time I was chairman of the Western Region of CORE.
And so we had decided that we would have a movement, a demonstration, and we would take
action against Bank of America throughout the state of California.
And that's what we did.
What did the Western Region cover?
All the states from I think we even included Colorado, but in California, in Oregon, in Washington.
You had really risen up in national CORE.
Yeah, I was on the advisory council, National Advisory Council.
That's where James L. Farmer Jr and I became friends in Floyd, McKissick, and I became friends.
We had quite a project against the Bank of America and the results were so good.
Although the Bank of America would never admit it.
But we forced the Bank of America and the San Diego Gas & Electric to start
hiring knee-grows and they did.
They would not talk to me directly, but they would talk to one of the ministers in the
community about could they find some knee-grows that come down and apply for jobs and everything.
So the minister and I were friends.
So I don't know, I got to know that.
But they did.
They hired and I argued in court that my defense was that if you look at the results.
But of course the prosecutor, the law is the law.
You broke the law.
You got it for trespassing.
So you broke the law?
For protest?
Yeah.
So what were the strategies that you used?
We had marches and we had sit-ins.
We had mail-ins.
We had SDG and E. We had mail-ins where we would mail-ins.
Get people to mail insured of their balance due for the month.
We would send either over or under and just kind of a nuisance factor.
But it was effective.
The coin in was we would stand in line at the Tellers window.
We would have a lot of pennies with us and we would either ask for pennies.
We would give them $10 and we would ask for some change.
We would stand there and count all the pennies.
We would bring pennies with us.
We got to the front of the window.
We would make our deposit or whatever we would do and we count out pennies one at a time
one at a time while the others were sitting on the floor singing our songs and things.
That was very effective.
It created some real results.
You look at those banks and things now.
Of course I always point out, I'm not saying that San Diego Corps take full credit for that.
There was a national movement going on.
In that context, we were able to be very effective and we laid it on the line.
We laid our jobs on the line.
I was called to appear in Sacramento at the board of trustees who were over the education
state superintendent and so forth.
I was called to come there to explain why I should not have my teaching credential removed
because of my leadership in Corps.
I had a lawyer who was in Corps as well and he went with me up to go to defend myself.
I don't know if it was just a scare tactic or they couldn't didn't want to pursue it
but they didn't take my credential.
That was a scary time.
Still it's intimidation.
That's a really intimidation.
That was, we did well.
We served our jail times.
We were able to serve our jail times on weekends.
I was still teaching school.
That's my wife.
I was teaching school and they said, well, you can serve as time on weekends, which I did.
There was only really effective times back then.
That was the core effort in this area, largely African-American.
Was it an interracial form of a question?
That's a good question.
I always point out to people that during those years there were more white members than
there were black members.
There were blacks and whites and the whites were probably two-thirds of the chapter.
I can remember going out strongly trying to recruit blacks to become members of Corps
or just to participate in some way with Corps.
Membership dues was $25.
Everyone could afford it but there were the times where blacks did.
In my opinion, we're very much afraid to be involved in the civil rights movement.
We didn't have any.
It took a lot of work to try to get them involved.
Even at our national meetings, we would discuss that a lot and at our national convention.
We had a big thing about trying to get more blacks involved.
I spent a lot of time on trying to do that.
That was tough.
The civil rights movement did not participate in the civil rights movement here in San
Diego to any degree.
What do you think that was?
I think it's because they were fearful of reprisals.
They did not want to risk whatever they had.
Of course, our comeback was, you don't have very much to begin with.
But whatever they had, they just did not want to risk that.
There were comments that would come back to me.
I would never be able to keep my job because they would find a way to fire me.
There was some attempt, I guess.
They just did not want to risk that even to the point where they would even admit to
their white friends that they even knew me, friends of mine.
It was pretty bad back in those days.
Whatever they had, they didn't want to risk losing it.
What were the historic origins of the Black community here?
Where did people come from?
Were they mostly the port or a war industry?
What brought people?
I understand that number came through the Navy.
A lot had no surveys or any research on it.
It seemed from talking with people that a number of people came from Texas area.
My understanding is they were introduced to San Diego through the Navy.
Some people got here, I don't know how, out there in a place called Ramona up there
that there were Negroes that settled there.
Back I don't know when that was, it was probably either the very early 1900s or late 1800s.
Another thing that's going to ask you back is asking about the interracial organization.
Is it already a large Latino population in San Diego at that time?
No.
There was not a large Latino population.
In fact, I don't know the stats on it.
Over in Logan Heights, that was known as a Black community.
There were very few Latinos living there.
Now, I think it's two thirds of Latino.
No, there just weren't very many.
The Mexican population was evidently very small back then because they certainly weren't visible.
That came later.
Another thing I wanted to ask about was other civil rights organizations.
You're here with COAR, but we're talking about early 60s when you have the student's
sit-in movement happening in other places, freedom rides, etc.
Were there other organizations that came into this area or that you were in contact with
and worked with or that you were paying attention to from afar?
The only organizations were the end of WACP, the Urban League.
Those were the only other organizations.
The end of WACP at that time was practically invisible.
They had no participation with us in the civil rights movement in San Diego.
The Urban League had no participation with us in the civil rights movement, but they
were here.
They were present.
You could contact them.
They end up WACP.
I say, not exaggerating.
I tried to find them and join them.
I understand I did.
I couldn't.
Wherever they were supposed to have an office, it wasn't open and the call couldn't contact
them.
I tried and tried.
The only organization other than CORE was, as I mentioned earlier, the Afro-American Association.
Did that continue or did that also fade out?
That faded out.
I became so involved in CORE and I don't know really what happened to it, but it kind
of just faded.
If you can keep us going with your involvement with CORE, so we're in the early 60s now,
they just take us forward.
One of the things that I did not mention, which I'm going to try to write about include
this part of it, is what people didn't actually realize about.
CORE was an organization that had internal problems too.
I was in a position where I was not only fighting white racism on the outside, but I was fighting
from the inside.
That opposition was in the form of, and I really don't know.
People, it was rumored by private citizens as well as the FBI.
We had the same problem as other chapters throughout the country had with infiltration
of other groups.
I only know that the peace movement was the only group that I knew was wanted to become
active in our organization and to exert some influence on what we did.
I refused that because I was very myopic in my view that we had enough on our plate
in our minds to try to conquer this racial problem against Negroes and America.
We had enough to do with that.
I was not interested in trying to use my personal resources and energy to take on some other
battles like the peace movement and so on.
The other issue was communism and Trotskyites.
I didn't know what the Trotskyites was.
The first thing I heard about communism was in high school and in history books, but
I didn't know anything about it.
They tried to accuse us of being communist.
I didn't know what they were talking about.
Anyhow, that was a way of labeling us the core and other organizations that you've been
infiltrated, communism and so on.
There was a battle.
I couldn't identify it.
I couldn't label it with any particular name, but there was a tremendous battle inside
our organization to oust me and take over the leadership with another person and another
group.
Those were some really, really, really tumultuous times and quite painful.
More painful, I would say, than the fight against the companies that were segregating,
were discriminating and employment and the housing and all that stuff.
It was more painful because it came from the people inside the organization, both blacks
and whites.
What was the result of those struggles?
Well, I've never been asked that question because the truth would be that the results of that
constant fighting, I can't think of a better way of fighting, was that I finally left.
And it was at the end of my jail sentences where I was doing them and all that.
And after that, I resigned and left and core just kind of.
So after you left, you really just have offered it?
When was that approximately?
I think it was 67.
I think there was an attempt by a friend of mine to take over the leadership.
But then when we left and went to DC for preparing to go over into Africa, Peace Corps,
my understanding was that the black power movement, the black panther movement and the
US Organization.
You remember the US Organization, there was a problem in San Diego.
And I was gone, so all of this is hearsay, but there was a lot of fighting between those
two organizations and so on.
And that really came in after you left.
Yeah, I wasn't here to see it.
You didn't even arrive.
I wasn't here and so core just kind of, I guess, faded away.
And then the sort of another way of came in behind it.
And that was pretty temporary.
I mean, there was a lot of fighting and stuff that went on.
But I don't think there was anyone that really grabbed onto the issues and pursued those
issues or tried to replace core or anything.
They just, I don't really understand it now.
It's what happened, but it just seemed to fade away us and black panthers, at least
in San Diego.
At least in San Diego, right?
Right.
So then you were in Lesotho for a couple of years?
No, I was there for one year, just a little under a year.
Okay.
That's another story in itself in that I always find, because of the way I grew up and the
family I grew up, I always find humor in a lot of these tragedies.
But when we went there, Lesotho is a country that's completely surrounded by South Africa.
And so getting in and out, you had to go through South Africa.
So when my wife and I went over to Lesotho, we had to stop in Johannesburg.
And so we were waiting for the flight to take us to Lesotho the next morning.
And so of course, apartheid was very strong.
So what they did was they had some room that was above the airport somewhere.
And that was for blacks.
That put you had to stay in that room.
You couldn't be in the airport anywhere.
You had to stay in that room until you're flight left.
Now these were for Africans.
And I was African then.
You know, I mean, it was the first time I was considered African.
Well, they put us up there in that room.
And we stayed there.
So I decided next morning that I was going to test it and just get out and walk around
the airport to see you.
And I did that.
And the next day I heard it was over the PA system that you know, the Harold Brown report
to such and such and such.
And my wife saw the some guys coming and chatting, standing around, chatting, chatting.
And she was getting worried because her full husband was out there going, you know,
probably get jailed and so forth.
It's out there.
But anyhow, one guy came up to me and I suspect that he was from the United States Embassy.
He came up to me and it kind of stood and looked the other way.
And Wispens had, is everything all right?
And I looked and said, yeah, as far as I'm concerned, you know, it's okay.
So we finally got, they got me back and the plane came and we're off to Lesotho.
And so now we are landing Lesotho.
There's a black Prime Minister Chief Leabua Jonathan and so on.
And we landed and the people seemed to be pretty joyous, you know.
My wife and I, two African Americans, two blacks.
I mean, blacks, we were African.
You know, and that's a term we use in America, blacks.
We were Africans.
So we turned in and they seemed to be, you know, greeted us well.
And so everything was really nice.
And then sometime later, maybe a month or so later, the Peace Corps volunteers came.
And so they'd land in the airport and coming out of those planes or all these white students,
you know.
It was really funny because I can imagine how Lesotho, the Fed, they were in shop
because they saw us and they knew anything about the Peace Corps.
They thought, oh, it's Peace Corps.
You know, Peace Corps, their mind was black.
And they saw all those whites.
And we had about, I think, three blacks Peace Corps workers.
So they came off and then, of course, the war was on.
We were, the Peace Corps was accused of all kinds of things, you know, and spying on the
Soutu and we just went on and on for that time.
And then while we were there.
And you were one of the directors of the program in New York.
Yeah, I was a deputy, deputy director.
Deputy director.
So were you being called in to answer to these things?
Or, no.
I mean, amble PR or no.
We had a Chargé d'Affaires and not an ambassador, a Chargé d'Affaires, but no, he never consulted
me.
I was invited to speak to, by different people in Maseru.
It's a capital to speak to their schools and so forth.
And there's this Negro Americans here, you know, which they've never seen before.
And I did and never asked me about, about what they called us about.
I guess, Africans in America, blacks in America.
And I would tell them, you know, they were, they were pretty sophisticated to many of them.
They knew what was going on around the country and they would ask all these questions about
how we were treated in America.
And I'd tell, you know, the truth, just like I'm answering questions here, I would tell.
Well, evidently, you know, we got back to the Chargé d'Affaires and his people and they
didn't like that because I was exposing America, I guess.
That's still the problem we have today.
I mean, that's why we're doing history right now.
They try to get America to know and understand what happened and what's happening now.
And I go to the third step, remember, my range, what should happen in the future.
But that was the situation in Lesotho.
And finally, Martin Luther King was assassinated.
And that was just too much for me to bear.
I could remain there out of the country and while all this was going on back home.
And so I told my wife to get packed because I've got to go back.
And so I did.
And we left and I guess the Chargé d'Affaires and we're very happy about that.
So we came back and.
So you had news reached you of what the response was in various cities.
Yeah.
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
What was going on?
And when Martin Luther King was killed, I went to the church to the AME church, African
Methodist Episcopal Church there in Lesotho.
And I asked we could have a memorial service there for Martin.
And he said, oh, yeah, of course.
And so we put together a really nice memorial service in honor of Martin.
And at the whole time we were there and before we got there, King Moshoeshoe II of Lesotho was
under house arrest because he opposed apartheid.
And the people were able to put in a Prime Minister Chief Leabua Jonathan who, whether he agreed with the partied
and not he went along with the partied.
But the king was sort of imprisoned.
So when we had this church memorial service who walks in the king almost brings tears
to my eyes now.
He walked in and set in through the whole service.
And I gave the remarks and so forth with an interpreter.
And my wife sang for him.
And then we had some talks by some of the Basotho leaders.
And it was just a beautiful, beautiful ceremony.
But when the king came in, you know, there's in South Africa, you probably have heard
this.
The ladies give a kind of a thrilling, a good, ululation.
It's just a sound that is, but it's high.
And so, you know, when he came in, it was just that.
You know, that we had been invited to his palace a couple times for a wife and a half.
But when he walked in there, boy, it was really something.
So after that, and you know, we were packed and everything.
And it came back to the States and went through the out processing of the Peace Corps and
did up trying to get back to San Diego.
And I couldn't find a position.
So that's where in the Florida, McKissick, and I started this company in Harlem, Florida
McKissick Enterprises.
And so I worked there for, I don't know, last lesson of year.
And then I moved to the, to the bank.
And I worked for Marine Midland Bank.
For which bank?
Marine Midland, and my DLA, and the home wall street.
And I did that.
And then from there, I was asked to come back by an old friend of mine who had been exposed
to corps when I was leading corps.
He wasn't a member, but he was around and knew.
And then he kind of became a little involved, not really.
But he and I got to know each other.
And so he had become a student, along with some others at San Diego State.
And they started, we're trying to start a black studies program.
And again, more in fighting and so forth.
And so they couldn't really get it going and everything.
So he called me in New York.
And I was a, you know, loan officer there at the bank.
And he said, asked me what I could, but I'd be interested in come back to San Diego.
Well, you know, I've been trying to get back to San Diego all this time.
So I said, well, it was a position where I would be assistant to the president.
And I thought about it because Wells Fargo had been holding the position for me also,
but they could meet my salary requirement.
And so I was just kind of waiting that out.
But my wife was, she was just happy she could be to get back to San Diego.
So I said, yes, so we came back to San Diego.
And then that's when I started working in September of 1971 at San Diego State.
And I was, you know, my plan was to organize that program,
plus some other responsibilities that I had on the campus.
But my plan was to get into the business area.
And I understand you're hiring some grounds.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was the first black administrator that the university had ever had.
And also, I, during my first year there, I hired some faculty members.
I hired from other who had just finished their PhDs.
And we're working at other universities and I hired them and brought them to San Diego State.
And then we've established a curriculum.
We established a major and a minor in back in that.
Those were very early years in black studies.
And I was able to get the university to accept our courses to fulfill the general education
requirements just like all the others.
I mean, that was a major coup.
And so that's one of the things I'm most proud of really.
So we got that major and got a minor and had our general education required courses.
And we went on and my plan was to do that for a year and then pursue my administrative career,
which my goal was to become a president of a college or university eventually.
And I had to stay there to finish what I wanted to finish in the Afro American Studies program
for two years.
And then I left and went over and
to the became the director of the computer services for the university.
I did the other administrative things on campus and I left the program and it was, you know,
it's now a full fledged department.
They changed the name to Africana Studies, rather than African American Studies.
But it's a full fledged department in San Diego State.
And you still retain ties, at least emotional ties, too?
Yeah, emotional, but I've been away since, but that was 73.
And that was your baby?
Yeah, that's right.
Baby is grown.
So that was a good experience.
And then you saw you went on to do other things at San Diego State.
And it became the associate dean of the within the administrative, I forget the title of
forget.
It was an associate dean of an administration, I forget what that was.
But then I went on to take the president asked me to head up the computer services for the
university.
And I did that.
And then in 1980, I went to become the associate dean in the College of Business Administration
and that's where I retired from there after, I guess, 26 years as the associate dean there.
And then I went into real estate development.
And that's what I'm still involved with.
Yeah.
And I retired from San Diego State in 2004, but I had dangled in real estate.
During my later years.
But I'm just reminding myself before that, what I did was, in 1987, I spearheaded the formation
of an organization called the Black Economic Development.
And it was called the Black Economic Development Task Force.
And I did that for 10 years.
Was I just in San Diego?
In San Diego.
Did that for 10 years?
And then I, as the associate dean, I founded a program, a certificate program in community
economic development and developed a curriculum there.
And use the faculty there in our college, in our business college, and a couple people
outside the university.
And that was a very successful program.
I did that until I retired in 2004.
And community members can participate?
Yes.
Yeah.
Community members, we had a full, it was about an eight month program.
And it turned out, but when I retired again, which I knew it would, they kept it there
because that program because of me, which is crazy.
But that's really a fact.
I knew, and so I knew, after I believe, they would let it go because they couldn't fund
it.
And then I raised funds to supplement what the university put into it in terms of offices
and a couple of people who worked for me.
But to run the program, I raised funds outside the program.
Plus, it got tremendous publicity.
The PR was very good, so the university liked that.
But they weren't going to put in a lot of money into the program.
And the program could not pay for itself because you just couldn't charge enough to make
it pay for itself.
You could do it in New York, charge that much at Columbia or NYU and places like that.
I'm familiar with them.
Their programs, they could charge a lot of money from people who would come and pay that
money, but we couldn't charge that much for it.
So it just couldn't pay for itself.
So I knew it wasn't bringing money.
And David was going to, which they did.
And at this point, to you to see how these things work so hard on.
But I was kind of used to it because the core disappeared.
I guess I failed to mention that I founded a program called Leadership Training.
As I finished core, I did that for a year.
Then I went into the Peace Corps.
But that was a good program.
The Leadership Training Program was really great.
And they got a lot of applause even from the labor department.
But then that went, I went, I went into the Peace Corps.
They tried to keep it going for a year, but that went poof.
So then I, but another thing I left out was, well, the Black Economic Development Task Force.
But you did that for 10 years.
And then when you're doing this, as you probably are aware of, when you're in these,
not for profit organizations.
I mean, you know, and you found them and you're instrumental in really getting things organized.
But 90% of the work ends up with you.
And so, from the Black Economic Development Task Force, that 10 after 10 years.
And I said, I couldn't do it any longer.
It went by the wayside.
Then I formed an organization while I was at the business school called,
it was an organization to bring together business, the business community,
to discuss racial matters.
And so I had a couple of friends who were very prominent in San Diego, multi-millionaires.
And so I got the two of them to join with me.
And we had that program where we met once a month at the hotel down there.
We had a mission value for lunch and had these discussions about race matters.
And we finally, after 10 years, I got tired and nobody took my place.
And so that went by the wayside.
So, have a name?
Yeah, it was called, it was called, Club was the acronym Community Leaders Undoing Biasis.
And that was a good group.
People said they really enjoyed that.
But the two guys that I brought, I mean, they have their own stuff going on and everything.
I convinced them that they needed to do something in this area.
And they said, okay, how?
Let's go.
You do it.
We're with you.
But they weren't going to get me and make this thing go and keep it going.
So that went by the wayside.
So everything that I, unfortunately, I guess some academicians would accuse me of not falling
the rules of delegation.
I'm not saying they were to delegate, you know.
But the reply to that, I heard someone say, well, delegate to whom.
You know, who?
There's the ass of people there.
And most people aren't willing to take on that kind of a burden.
And it's a lot of work.
Well, let me ask you then, certainly fabric, because you said something earlier that really
caught my attention about, you know, studying what's happened in the past and what's happening
now.
And then you're at the piece that you like to add to it and what should have done.
Yes.
So looking back on this amazing career and all of these things that you've involved in
and bringing it up to the present and where we are now and what we're facing now, what
should happen?
The first thing is that we need to look at the past and see what happened.
And then to find some lessons from that.
As an example, there was a big fight amongst black members of the community throughout the
country, I think, that not to follow this thing on the integration.
That was necessary.
It shouldn't be a thing.
And as I read some time later, that core must have been after I left, but they had some
in the National Committee and the National Convention about, you know, not having this
is even part of the constitution and bylaws of having this thing about integration.
Well, some people felt that that was the way to solve this problem, of course, and to
go through the others felt that that wasn't the way.
So I think we need to learn the lessons back then.
And we need to learn lessons about what happened.
I mean, and that's what I'm hoping to get a book written to kind of show as you've been
asking me these questions.
How do you get to that point where you become militant or whatever they want to call us
back in those days?
How do you get to that point?
I was a mild matter, quiet kid, shy, who was interested in athletics and who excelled
in athletics and so on.
But that's what I knew.
How do I get to this point where I'm willing to sacrifice my life and my career and everything
else to this point?
I wasn't crazy and not insane.
So I hope to address that.
And then to get into the future and say, okay, what are we doing now?
We had the civil rights movement.
We had all the past of slavery and post-slavery and leading up to the civil rights movement.
Now what do we do?
There was one area that we really haven't addressed.
And the reason we didn't address it because we, including Martin Luther King and all the
children of Floyd McKissie and the urban, the guy Whitney M. Young Jr and the way we didn't have
the time to even think about doing anything but kicking doors open and getting jobs for
our people and all this stuff and getting educated and getting into these colleges and
all this stuff.
But the one area that we didn't address for a number of reasons was this idea of how we
fit into capitalism and how we can survive and progress under capitalism.
I mean, even if you become a first class citizen, I mean, that's not enough.
So I began many, many years ago to start thinking about building wealth and what that meant.
And that's why I started the Black Economic Development Task Force, the Community Economic
Development Group at the University and stuff like that because there's a need for us,
all of us really, whites and blacks and Latinas, to really understand capitalism, how it
works and what we need to do to benefit from this thing.
You're not going to replace capitalism as Senator Bernie Sanders might think he can do but we'd
like to do it.
But we've got to understand it and then we've got to understand very strongly that capitalism
wasn't just a word that was thrown up there.
Capitalism means something in the first place.
The word capital is very important in our economic system.
That's why I called it capitalism.
And so a lot of people never, when I taught the class at San Diego State in the program
that I found it, they didn't really connect that.
I mean, you need capital if you're really going to be successful in America.
Maybe you only have a little bit of capital that comes through your savings.
But you have to have some savings.
You can't spend everything that comes into your household.
So my thing is we've got to really focus now on educating, not just getting people
and education in high school and getting there on the college.
But getting them some education in this whole area of our economic system and how to survive
and prosper in that.
And so that's where I think we should be going.
As I get into my book, I'm going to have a part of it devoted to pointing that out.
This is what we should do.
We haven't done it in the past.
We weren't able to do it.
I mean Martin Luther King has great as he was, you know, anything about economics and
business and all that stuff.
It wasn't his area.
He was a theology.
And so we really I think have got to, and that's why I started the Black Economic Development
Task Force was to get us thinking about, I mean, at that time in 1987 when we started
that, I mean, Black people couldn't even get that out of that Black, what?
I mean, economics, I mean, they couldn't form those two words together.
And so now they can because we had the program and there's been more around the country
about it, but I don't hear about Black wealth.
And we many of us have been taught that wealth is bad.
Money, money, money, what did they say?
Money, district money, corrupts, money, corrupts and all that.
And until, you know, in my class and I explained how money can help, but you've got to have
money to help and to survive.
And the more you have through whatever profession or you decide to go into through your savings
and all that, through capital, if you're in the real state development like I am, you
know, you need capital, you just can't go out there and you got to purchase land and
build and that takes money.
And so we, one of the big things that stands in the way of that, of our getting involved
in that as a Black population is that we have never learned to work together, you know,
other than the church.
You know, we have really, and I'm not so sure about the church.
There's a lot of not getting along in the church, but we need to really focus now on that
area and learn how to really be successful.
And really, I mean, what I see happening now, which, which, which, you know, I hesitate
to do because I'm not around the whole, I don't know what's going on around the country
in that way.
But what I see happening is that after the Civil Rights Movement, we hit a wall as Black
people.
We hit a wall and we're not doing it.
We got some, some people got some jobs, good jobs.
I'm one of them.
You know, we got good jobs.
My wife got a good job.
My friends, our friends, you know, in the fraternity, they all had good jobs.
But we still have so much poverty and within the Black population, we have so much lack
of education within the Black population.
We have so much, so many people under the criminal justice system.
You know, I mean, these are all problems that we have, that we have not really found
a way to address them.
And usually all this stuff, education and all that stuff, you know, takes, takes money.
And one of the things that we need to learn about capitalism is that, you know, capitalism
exists on spending, spenders.
And we've become some of the greatest spenders around.
I mean, Black folks spend a lot of their money.
In fact, Tony.
But we become generators.
That's right.
They never, that's right.
We're always looking for jobs, but we don't supply jobs, create jobs.
And some, this is the question of what power looks like.
Yeah.
Or as an equation, and this is a piece of that.
Yeah, exactly.
And when you're talking about it, me and the conversation, I had with a long time, long,
long time activists in Georgia, and I asked him, we were talking about when Black, the
phrase Black power first started.
Yeah.
It's so clear.
And he asked him what he thought, what it meant to him.
And he said economic power.
And some determination and economic power.
Yes.
That's what it's got to be.
I'm reminded of that when you were in the middle of it.
Yes.
You reminded me just now the term self-determination.
That was something that was very strong within me.
It just motivated me so much because I could see one day where we would have things in
our hands where we could determine for ourselves what we wanted to do.
And I think that was one of the problems with me, with the the peace movement and the trotsky
IH's and communists and all that stuff.
I mean, first of all, they were all white.
And then all blacks involved in that.
And secondly, they wanted to impose their will on core.
And I mean, I was just dead set against that because I was very, very interested in
surn with self-determination.
And I used that term in med meetings in core.
But that's where I see us going.
But you know, there has to be an example.
And so when I left retired from San Diego State, I set out to make an example of how it
can be done.
And that's why I'm in real estate and land development now.
And I'm with a couple partners and so forth.
I think they have to see it happen.
And they have to see it happen not by an athlete, not by someone who broke into the movies,
the movie star.
You know, at least they see it happening with one of the block blocking, you know, these
the guy in the music industry, these guys, rap, rap guys, you know, see it happening?
Few, you know.
But we've got to find a way to show our kids that, you know, say, oh, how brown, Mr.
Brown is a millionaire.
He is, yeah.
Who he played for?
Exactly.
And they've got to see examples of that.
Our son who played basketball for Stanford, he, the coach, I guess, had them going out
in the community and talking to kids and so forth.
So our son told us, and they said he went out to talk to a group of kids and he was
unprepared to talk with them about school and things like that.
And before he could really, your son said, you're kids right at the hands.
How much your shoes cost?
You know, tennis shoes, you know.
What kind of car do you drive?
This went on and on like that.
It was so frustrating for him.
I mean, it's the mist, the mark so much, you know.
And that's what, I mean, what surprises me though, is that so much of that still exists
to this day.
And I go around and meet my fraternity and so forth.
I mean, you know, doctors, lawyers, businessmen, educators, all in high positions.
We all had great positions, but no education really in business, economics, and that sort
of thing.
So the medicine, a lot of doctors, not in and so, but I just think that's the next step.
And I said this back in about 1980s and I wrote, we used to have black economic summits.
That was my idea, you know, to bring people together and talk about economics.
And we did that for several years.
And in our program, we would always have something from me in front of the program.
And I remember talking about, you know, what we should be doing and bringing about a
real consciousness of making economics apart, should be the next step.
That's what I used with the next step of the civil rights movement, should be in economic
development.
Well, I thought it was going to take off around the country.
You know, I thought I saw signs of things happening and so forth, but not really.
I think, you know, we hit a wall.
And as an example, here in San Diego, and I must admit, I just don't have a feel for
what's going on around the country and the communities and so forth.
I know it's going on politically.
But we just, you know, I see a wall and we haven't really, I mean, we've gotten some jobs
as I said earlier, but you know, that's it.
San Diego, when core days, when we had core, we had a voice.
The city fathers and so forth, you know, when things came up, as other guys, core came
to mind.
We don't have a voice now.
I just met with the, well, it's met.
I've been talking with the, the President, CEO of San Diego, Urban League and he wanted
to know, you know, get my thoughts and things on how the Urban League could become more
effective and so on.
So we've been meeting so forth and I put together a group of guys to, as kind of a think tank
to just sit around and talk with him and so forth.
And we did that one Saturday and we'd probably do it again.
But someone has to kind of take the lead, you know, and not only in the African American
community, but I mean, it's the same applies for the Latino community, same as the Filipino
community and the same.
You know, with the Asian.
Yeah, I mean, and do you see some potential because some, you know, especially with, you're
giving an example of core and some of the groups that, sometimes it's the seed of anger
that, or, you know, that motivation.
Yeah, absolutely.
So do you see any potential then, you know, with what we see, we'll solve it with the
Black Lives Matter or with the folks who are following Senator Bernie Sanders, they've talked
about.
Do you see any of that emotional, whatever is driving those movements that gives you
some hope at all?
Unfortunately, no.
You know, I don't, and you're absolutely right and we've said that, you know, years back,
you know, there's got to be some anger, you know, or you don't get anything done.
Somebody has to do something to cause a lot of commotion and then you will get people's
attention.
But, without that, you know, so the only place that I know of where it can be done is,
it has to be forced on them in the schools.
And I thought the Black Studies programs around the country would do that, but I mean, I don't
see any signs of their annoying.
I mean, talking about your project here, I mean, the need for it is so great because people
don't even know about it.
People in my age group here in San Diego, you just say something about the Civil Rights
Movement in San Diego, they go, what?
I don't know.
There was a Civil Rights Movement in San Diego.
And those are the people in, you know, my age group should have known about it, much
not, much less than participating in it, they should have really known about it, but
then they've been not a younger people.
They have no idea.
I can remember speaking to a class at San Diego State when we formed the Black, when we formed
the African American Studies program, it must have been 1972.
And I was asked by one of the faculty members that I hired to come around and speak to
this group about her class about the Civil Rights Movement and I went in there, none of
them knew anything.
Now that was back then.
So we really have a problem, I think.
I don't know how else we can do it unless it's force fed through the schools that people,
well, my goal, one of my goals was in the African American Studies program that I got organized
at San Diego State was to eventually market it, market it to the total university.
I mean because that had just made sense to me, it just can't be for Black students.
And so I sort of got ousted a little bit because of some more internal things.
I don't know.
I wish to write people around the country who were much more involved than I and so forth.
They could write about this internal stuff that happens.
I bet you Reverend Jesse L. Jackson Sr could write a whole lot about it and it's got started this,
who got involved with starting this project at the Charles, I mean Lewis, John, John.
I bet you they could tell you a whole lot of stories about the infighting and stuff that
went on that sort of kept the progress from being more than it was.
So I'll tell you, we're still having the same fights and conversations that we were saying
about it shouldn't, Black studies shouldn't just be over here stuck in its corner.
These are classes that should be in the general curriculum.
Absolutely.
You know I'm much older now more tired, better known as worn out.
Where is you?
Honestly, when I finished the Civil Rights Movement, I mean I didn't know what was going on
at the time.
My left core, I mean my nervous system was shot.
I couldn't sit at a meeting or talk to people about it.
I couldn't even, my nervous system was completely shot.
I didn't realize what was going on but that was close to a nervous breakdown.
So not uncommon.
I don't know how to talk to other activists.
Absolutely.
I'm a bit sad.
High stress.
Yeah, high stress.
Almost dramatic stress in some cases.
You're the first person.
I've thought about that a lot and I've said it to my wife.
But you know, I mean I don't sleep well and I play back a lot of stuff over all those
years and they hit me one time.
You know, I mean that's what they're talking about, about people coming back from the
wars and stuff, post-traumatic stress.
Same stuff.
Absolutely the same stuff.
And I think it's just beginnings, some of the activists are just beginning to recognize
that they're sad.
And there are some activists who tore them apart early on, and they ended up strong out
on drugs.
Yeah, they couldn't deal with that.
I think that's where we need to go.
That's part of the answer anyhow.
I think that we've got to really get economic minded.
And we've got to, do you remember last name was Brown.
I'm having trouble.
I'm wearing you out, right?
Tony, Tony Brown?
You know about Tony Brown?
Tony Brown had a program on KPBS for some years.
And his focus was on economics, black businesses and all this stuff.
And I have a video tape that he put together showing how black spending and how blacks only
spent 1% or less in those black communities.
And he's talking about back years and years.
But Tony, I don't know what happened to him.
I don't think he died.
But he sort of disappeared.
He put out a movie called Weight Girl.
Weight Girl is in what you think he's talking about.
He's talking about the drugs that was called Weight Girl.
And he put out that movie and I helped him to get it out here in San Diego and stuff.
But Tony was very active in this area of building black businesses and creating wealth among
him.
He used the word wealth so much.
But that's what he was talking about doing that.
So maybe, you know, if we had somebody like on the level of Representative John Lewis in Congress, which
reminds me, I don't know why we don't get this kind of a message from the black business.
I don't know why we don't get this message.
I don't see any leadership coming from them.
Although I like them.
I love them because they're in these positions and stuff.
But I don't see any real leadership coming.
And Reverend Jesse L. Jackson Sr disappeared and then we have Reverend Al Sharpton at him.
But I remember Jesse used to come out here in San Diego many, many years ago.
He would be talking and talking and talking about him and treating all this stuff.
But never, nothing, not a word about the importance of economics.
I remember saying that back in those years.
Well, we don't have anybody in leadership positions to speak to that.
If I could get my hands on Hillary Rodham Clinton, I would twist her arm.
Hillary Rodham Clinton, I would make a $5 donation.
Now listen.
I'm sure it brings you five.
Yeah, it brings you close.
She got a website.
I understand.
You're from?
Well, she ever, you know, where does that go?
Oh, well.
Interesting world.
Yeah.
Very interesting.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History and Culture.